this planet what's it call everyone is
mine to torment hey youtubers is charlie
welcome to my channel emergency awesome
I'm such a huge sci-fi and fantasy nerd
i decided to start making videos to talk
about all my favorite fandoms with you
guys right now i'm making about six to
eight videos a week including stuff like
Doctor Who Walking Dead game of thrones
Legend of Korra American Horror Story
agents of shield sleepy hollow
supernatural and tons more stuff I just
like to think of YouTube is a place full
of friends that you haven't met yet
think of it as like a less disgusting
version of tumblr if it were run by a
bed from community I also do videos for
a lot of the big movie franchises that I
really love like The Hobbit Star Wars
main of Steel marvel I'm even working on
starting to do video game videos pretty
soon too every once in a while I partner
up with big TV networks like BBC America
for stuff like Doctor Who week in case
you didn't see it we did a big live
stream before the 50th anniversary it
was so much fun and i'll be doing a
bunch more awesome stuff for the
Christmas special and there's Sherlock
in January too I tried to do new shows
and new videos based on suggestions that
you guys give me all the time I even
give away a ton of free stuff as often
as possible I've got a lot of new stuff
coming this December and January so be
sure to subscribe to my channel so you
can have fun nerding out with the rest
of us you can also find links to all my
social counts on the top of my channel
page too so there's any awesome sci-fi
or fantasy or genre shows or movies that
you guys really want to talk about
please let me know and I'll add it to
the list of videos that I do thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives
you